E aí
G1
Oi boa tarde e querem larga se não
resistente e aqui estão eu tenho dá
sorte porque eu tenho o tema mais sexy
desta alto mais Sexy deste deste tempo é
reparar sexo e morte sobre temas
favoritos nossa literatura e do cinema
não é é
e por outro lado esse também pensar um
bocadinho a morte bom e talvez o último
tava das cidades contemporâneas
eu não estou falando isso
e na verdade últimos agora é uma morte
asséptica
institucionalizada pela ocorre longe do
ambiente familiar e Portanto a morte
existe mas não se vê
vocês devem estar com uma grande
expectativa porque falar de amor não é
verdade a partir deste nome da morte o
que eles quer falar é da vida se quer
vir aqui para mim vocês a todo
e
numa perspectiva simbólica
na arena romana a morte fazia de
comparsa para que no final a vida ter um
faço
bom e na verdade aquilo que eu pretendo
falar é desse temos da Vida em todas as
suas dimensões biológica essa
psicossocial seja Symbol
e vocês sabem que o ser humano é o único
ser vivo sabe que vai morrer
e esta é uma característica Única dos
seres humanos e os distingue de outras
peças
O
que significa o quê que esta consciência
nos meses e da nossa atitude
para com eles a fiz existenciais que nós
procuramos resolver de formas tão
distintas como a ciência a filosofia
ou a religião
a partir desta ideia de mortes quero
falar da vida
não apenas da vida o ponto de vista da
Sobrevivência biológica
Ah não já está bem procurando é uma vida
plena nos completo Mas faça sentido
se
realize
e a partir desta ideia de morte nós
valorizamos a vida como algo que é
o único mas passageiros
e nós
temos sabemos com vamos correr porque
temos uma coisa muito importante nós
temos memória RAM
o que que significa
e nós conseguimos planear aqui que vamos
fazer hoje a noite amanhã
o que podemos fazer daqui 1 semana daqui
a um ano nós conseguimos
antecipar o futuro
e
lutemos pela vida
ficou lutar pela vida significa
o botar amor na verdade
e
Pensamos muito neste conceito de rota da
Morte e sabe qual é o sinônimo de
utilize para a rota da morte
e é eternidade que é uma coisa muito
sedutora não é
viver para sempre mas a eternidade é uma
possibilidade a biológica
e nem a eternidade A Arte
da adaptação que responsável pela
evolução das espécies na eternidade as
terminação
os leitos unidade
e a imutabilidade logo na eternidade não
lives on
e as nossas células estão programadas
Para Morrer nós sabemos Aí se apoptose
nós temos programados para Morrer
bom e o que é muito importante e
paradoxal é que a vida
sustentis nesta auto-regulação internas
que prevê a frase a sua falência
é só pensar nisso e por exemplo
e as células cancerígenas não possuem
esta característica
elas no ambiente favorável
e elas crescem e desenvolvem-se
eternamente
e eu estou a falar de desvirar vamos ter
muitos cuidar e seria uma grátis
O que é verdade também é que nos últimos
e já ouvimos Amei hoje é que nos últimos
100 anos na esperança de vida tem
aumentado bastante
melhoria das condições de vida das
pessoas com aparecimento em particular
de duas coisas muito importantes que
aumentar as seguintes passagens os
antibióticos
os dias vacina
tu és vacina é que nós o patinho a si
mesmo
foram foram dois momentos muito
importantes e dar um salve para o
aumento da esperança de vida de cada um
o outro lado se aumentamos as processa
vida esse as nossas células estão
programadas morrer e significa o que
realmente para ser vivida também a uma
maior incidência de doenças negativas
relacionadas com a idade mesmo
mas na prática Isso significa que
podemos viver mais
é mas provavelmente com mais doença
o espírito alguns desafios
o desafio mais importante é esta mudança
paradigmática
em que a vida enquanto conceito absoluto
ele é progressivamente substituído por
esta ideia de qualidade e
e
por outro lado as continuamos
esperançosamente aproveitar na ciência
médica ele desenvolva tratamento para a
cura destas doenças
é mas
bom e quando ele chega no cura
e o quando os tratamentos deixa-me ser
eficazes
E na verdade a maioria das doenças
degenerativas não tem cura
e nós conseguimos fazer é controlar
prevenir as suas complicações E com isso
garantir o melhor sobrevida garantir uma
melhor qualidade de vida destas pessoas
eu estou a falar doenças é comum como as
doenças vasculares do miocárdio ou AVC
doenças neurológicas como as doenças
ou quem
nasceu estágios mais avançados
e quando as pessoas
passam por um processo deve evidenciam
uma doença pode ser mais ou menos
esperava
é a primeira coisa que pensam é
E aí
É uma sensação de perda de controle
resposta
E aí
nessa sensação de perda de controle elas
busca uma razão uma causa um nexo de
causalidade
É mas no pensamento moderno atual
e Nós aprendemos
pensamento pós-moderno
é Mas aprendemos que lhe ver Beatriz
e a liberdade de escolha são Pilares
muito importantes e fundamentais da
nossa existência
Oi sumiu
a vida é uma sucessão de coisas
E aprendemos a rejeitar a ideias como
Fatalidade
sorte fado
a vida é uma sucessão de escolha
a esse eu sou responsável
por aqui eu faço ou por aqui e acontece
O que é provável que eu quando
eu penso sobre as causas aqui acontecer
eu não faço o juízo da atual ou não vou
só à procura de uma razão Portugal
e eu procuro também uma razão objetiva
e o que é que eu fiz para merecer isso
E se eu sou responsável por aquilo que
faço
e o que é que eu fiz errado
de repente
o sentimento começa a pesar sobre os
nossos
G1
e
quando percebemos que por vezes não
encontramos uma razão objetiva
para aquilo que nos acontece o nosso
esforço deve ser direcionado para
aceitação dessas propostas
por exemplo
você sabe mas cerca de dois terços e
uma das doenças cancerígenas elas tem
como elas resultam Dilma olha aleatória
no processo de aplicação solar ou seja
elas devem
o caso
e o esforço que é feito é um esforço da
situação dessas circunstâncias quando
olhamos para Estas pessoas nós temos
e é vê-las como corajosas para lá das
suas circunstâncias ou em função das
circunstâncias
e
na verdade existe uma luta um confronto
E durante esta situação
este confronto ou Esta luta não é contra
a doença se instalar
e ali existentes
e não confronto tem a ver com a
aprendizagem cada um tem que fazer
só para saber lidar com a situação e
integrar a vida ou Se quisermos integrar
a doença como algo que ela tem que dizer
as marchas
e nós não controlamos
e nem a progressão
nem o seu prognóstico
O que podemos fazer
é nesta altura existe uma coisa que se
chama cuidados para
obter são cuidados político os cuidados
paliativos já não se destinam ao
controle da doença mas sim ao controle
os seus sintomas na verdade o que eles
pretendem é garantir
é o máximo de qualidade de vida e
bem-estar possível as pessoas envolvidas
E aí
e se os cuidados paliativos
já não conseguem controlar o sofrimento
provocado por estas doenças
o que que acontece
estamos a falar de qualidade de vida
é do nosso país e provavelmente noutros
países onde estes debates vão acontecer
quando falamos sobre o final de vida
normalmente tentamos debate Na discussão
da
localização da Ásia ou reconhecido
destino
é uma forma muito genérica
eutanásia é o ato intencional de
participar trocar antecipar a morte de
alguém mas forma indolor como forma de
terminar com seu sofrimento extremo
O que é causada negócio não curava
Aqui
também
está tudo é sempre foi com seu
consentimento Expresso
e por suicídio assistido é quando alguém
decide antecipar a sua morte mas para o
efeito Isabela cinza de alguém
habitualmente um profissional de saúde e
fornece os meios para que eu possa
praticar é sábado
é mas
e antes de falar
a situação da Morte permitam voltar aos
cuidados com a
em primeiro lugar porque entendeu
E agora é minha opinião entendeu a favor
da legalização da eutanásia
ele também quero cuidados para o meu tio
se Deus precisar
o que eu digo Ôxe por quê
E aí
as duas vezes pai
que a legalização da eutanásia e surge
como uma oposição aos cuidados
paliativos e tem sujas entre eles um
certo ou incerto existe momentos na
qualidade de vida destas pessoas no
limite a legalização da eutanásia pode
subir entender como uma espécie de
engenharia social
e nada mais falso
Olá eu sou a favor da eutanásia mas
também quero uma rede de cuidados
paliativos
O que funciona de qualidade
é porque eu tenho Ásia e cuidados
paliativos
eles são complementares eles devem
coexistir numa sociedade desenvolvida
ambos tem igual valor social
Olá meus this
Olá eu sou a favor da legalização da
eutanásia
é mas se ela precisar eu não sei se quer
provavelmente não
isso não é uma contradição
e o pior sabemos é que a maioria das
pessoas em sinal de vida não quer
e no Inter
abraço sempre uma maioria muito poucos
que seja para qual os cuidados
paliativos já não conseguem melhorar o
seu sobrinho
é
nesta altura
Estas pessoas devem ter uma alternativa
é uma outra opção
é uma saída alternativa sobre a qual
elas possam pensar
E aí
bom e uma decisão final de linha
ela é radical na sua essência
é mas ela deve estar
sobre a vontade individual uma vontade
individual sobre controle desta vontade
individual e ela seja livre e
esclarecida
a realização da eutanásia
permite morrer com dignidade
e
esse elas deve estar sob controle desta
Liberdade individual é aqui que assenta
o principal argumento daqueles que são
os famosos
e o direito de seguro
e o direito de decidir sobre a sua
própria vida
bom e que já não é digno prolongar a
vida de alguém contra sua própria
vontade quando está bem
se eu ligasse a organização do Canazio
não é contra o direito à Vida
é mas ela considera EA vida
e na sua Plenitude
já se perdeu quando alguém está aí
a alegação da Ásia considere que o
direito à Vida é alvo inalienável
É mas esse direito não impõe um dever de
viver
e na verdade
e na sua radicalidade
a eutanásia é permitido o exercício da
liberdade
e na verdade ela permite o último oxide
e Como disse no início ao longo deste
curso eu partir desta ideia de morte
pois que falar sobre a vida
é nestas circunstâncias fazemos sempre
um balanço onde a nossa história de vida
emerge com toda a sua força simbólica
e o que fizemos
e o que conquistamos
é aonde estamos o caminho da gostaríamos
de fazer
e pensamos nossa família Todas aquelas
pessoas queridas na procissão que nos
realiza
é mas também Devemos pensar o quanto
esta jornada que é a vida
e nos completas
e o quanto
é a vida tem sido Rosa fraco não e o
quanto podemos estar gratos por isso o e
confesso que esta ideia gratidão é algo
que me ajuda a lidar usar muito com
forno Meu final vida e tanto aqui que eu
tenho para dizer é muito obrigado e
vivam sim
E aí